every night we look up and see
stars twinkling merrily in the sky but
most people hardly ever take a moment to
think about their origins
age and how far away they are but some
stars are practically the same age as
the universe
just imagine many stars were born at the
same time with the universe
and strange as it may seem are just as
luminous as young ones
according to scientific estimates our
universe is approximately 13.8 billion
years old
we can't but admit that this figure is
rather impressive compared to the age of
the earth for example
which is just four and a half billion
years
i wonder if you've ever heard about the
methuselah star
also known as hd140283
so what's so special about this star
incidentally it's sage
which according to scientists is over 14
billion years
extraordinary isn't it let's take a look
at it then
[Music]
but before we set off on our journey
through the universe i'd like to remind
you of my channel in telegram
there i tell you about various phenomena
in space boast images of remote planets
and share rather exciting content
if you are also into things going on out
there feel free to subscribe
the link is in this video's description
now back to the story
as i've already mentioned the universe
is over 13.8 billion years old
so how can it possibly contain a star
older than itself
for more than 100 years astronomers have
been observing a strange star
190 light years away from the earth in
the constellation
libra it travels at a speed of about 1.3
million kilometers per hour but its most
peculiar feature is its age
hd140283 is considered one of the eldest
stars in the universe
known to science today
in the year 2000 scientists tried to
estimate its
age they were guided by data that had
been collected by the hipparchus
satellite launched by the european space
agency
and thus they got the figure of 16
billion years
the generally accepted age of the
universe was 13.8 billion years
which had been confirmed by observations
the discrepancy between the two values
prompted a lot of debate how can a star
be older than the universe
or else how can the universe be younger
than a star
as for its unusual name the star was
dubbed after a biblical character
methuselah
who according to scripture lived to be
969 years old
the star methuselah is clearly genuinely
old
it is none other than a sub giant
consisting mainly of hydrogen and helium
it contains a negligible amount of iron
which may only mean that this object was
formed before
iron had become such a widespread
element but how can a star be about 2
billion
years older than the environment it
finds itself in
it appeared to be a perplexing paradox
astronomer howard bond and his
colleagues from pennsylvania state
university
proceeded to double check the value of
the star's age
they too were struck by the fact that
methuselah had been born before the
universe
in their task they had to go through 11
observational data sets collected in the
period from 2003 to 2011 by the fine
guidance sensors of the hubble space
telescope
the sensors measure stars positions
distances
and radiation energy it is possible to
produce precise results in estimating
the age of an object
by studying its parallax and using
spectroscopy and photometry
according to bond not knowing the
precise distance to hd140283
remained one of the reasons the age may
have engaged wrongly
the distances had to be scrupulously
measured in order to calculate the
object's luminosity with a view to
estimating the object's age
the brighter the star the younger it
actually is
the scientists were also studying the
parallax and keeping watch on the star's
position in the sky for a year
theoretical models also left a lot to be
desired
the scientists were uncertain as to the
precise rate of nuclear reactions
and couldn't put their finger on the
role of diffusion of certain elements
in the star's outer layers that is why
the team considered the possibility of a
faster thermonuclear synthesis
if the star really burned faster than
ordinary ones do
then it was supposed to be really
younger than previously estimated
bond added that oxygen at hd140283
also had to be reckoned with the ratio
of oxygen to iron was rather high
and in the first millions of years of
the universe's evolution there wasn't
that much oxygen around
this was another piece of evidence
confirming methuselah's younger age
eventually the value bond and his
colleagues produced was 14.46 billion
years
plus minus 800 million years
this of course is significantly less
than 16 billion
but still more than the age of the
universe not counting the margin of
error of 800 million years
according to robert matthews a british
physicist from aston university in
birmingham who wasn't on the research
team
the estimates may have been corrupted by
both accidental and systematic errors
the most precise up-to-date value of the
star's age was in conflict with the age
of the universe
calculated using relic radiation the
conflict could be resolved
only by giving the result the larger
margin of error
in later research the star was gauged to
be still younger
in 2014 a study titled
sequel was published where the authors
lowered the estimate of methuselah's age
to 14.27 billion years
but admittedly there was still the
margin of error of 7
800 million years strangely
the star's age still beat that of the
universe
according to bond the similarity between
the values of the age of the universe
and its oldest star proves the
consistency of the big bang theory
besides the values were produced by
different methods of analysis
thanks to meticulous observations the
results are not as scattered as they
were in the 1990s
when ancient stars were estimated at 19
or even 20 billion years
at least now the inaccuracies do not
clash with the accepted models
robert matthews however maintains that
the issue is anything but solved
as recently as in july 2019 scientists
participated in an international
cosmology conference at the calvary
institute for theoretical physics in
santa barbara
california where they analyzed studies
of the universe's supposed age
judging by the galaxy's nearest to us
the universe is several hundred million
years younger than suggested by the
results of relict radiation calculations
for all we know our universe may turn
out to be just 11.4 billion years old
and the new estimates shouldn't be
casually dismissed
after all one of the authors was a nobel
prize laureate
astrophysicist adam reece from the space
telescope science institute
sdsci the conclusions are drawn on the
concept of the universe's expansion
suggested by edwin hubble back in 1929
the expansion of the universe is a
fundamental concept in the big bang
theory
if the universe has always been
expanding shouldn't there be a starting
point for the process
that could be calculated
according to the latest data the rate of
expansion is in fact
10 percent higher than suggested by
planck according to planck's team
the rate of the universe's expansion is
67.4 kilometers per second per megapasc
the latest measurements produce the
value of around 73.74 kilometers per
second per megapasc
rhys maintains that there should be a
difference between the real rate of
expansion today
and the rate implied by the physics of
the early universe
firstly it is obvious that accepted
theories have to be seriously questioned
and secondly there is the dark matter
and dark energy riddle
since the hubble constant produces a
bigger value for the rate of expansion
it suggests that the universe is younger
than we think
the 67.74 constant corresponds to the
age of 13.8 billion years
the 73 or even 77 constant corresponds
to the age of not more than 12.7
billion years quite recently a study was
published in the science magazine which
claims the hubble constant to be 82.4
it should be mentioned it's a
well-reputed magazine
the 82.4 constant corresponds to the age
of 11.4 billion years
either way the star hd 140283
still appears older than the universe
matthews believes this is a task to be
handled by cosmologists
rather than astrophysicists to define
the age precisely it isn't stars that
have to be studied
but more complex structures of the
universe
so why would the universe appear younger
than this one star
matthews suggests at least two possible
explanations
as is so often the case with the history
of science
the end result is likely to turn out to
be a combination of the two versions
in short there may be observation errors
caused by something we do not fully
understand
and also there may be some blanks in our
knowledge of the universe's dynamics
for example the dark matter force which
as it were has been in charge of the
expansion of the universe for billions
of years
is still rather baffling to us thus the
age paradox could well be accounted for
by dark energy variations
and changes in the expansion rate
according to theorists
all this may have to do with the
fundamentals of the nature of gravity
in particular the causal set theory
which leads us to believe that by
measuring gravitational waves
we may get to the bottom of the paradox
gravitational waves are hard to measure
just to give you an idea they were first
detected as recently as in 2015.
astrophysicists stephen feeney from the
flatiron institute believes that a major
scientific breakthrough on this front
may take place in the next thousand
years
and the bizarre phenomenon of the age of
hd140283
is bound to reveal larger and more
scientifically complex things
that are yet to be discovered and
explored
today we're able to access a lot of
information about space objects
discoveries in astronomy and studies of
prominent scientists
it is quite within our power to share
this information and bring as many
inquiring minds up to date as possible
if you are as impressed by such like
discoveries and incredible facts
do share this video with friends or
simply hit the like button or the bell
button
we will greatly appreciate it let's keep
in touch
[Music]
you